if its leadership election was meant to
show that you keep professionalized
could move beyond the faction fighting
and the backbiting of recent years it's
not doing a very good job it has been so
far a bit of an embarrassment for the
party Stephen will start off as the
overwhelming favorite but then he failed
to submit his nomination papers on time
he blamed the you Kip website saying it
was impossible to use and then came
assaulting more serious story which was
that when he ran for a police and crime
Commissioner he hadn't announced a
previous drunk-driving conviction now
when you run for police and crime
Commissioner you're not meant to have
had any criminal convictions even if
they're spent if you're going to run so
we wait until tomorrow for the labor for
the you Kip national executive committee
to rule on whether Steven wolf can stand
or not see more visit the only candidate
to be expected to sound he's in a bit of
trouble Suzanne Evans isn't standing at
all because she's not allowed to because
she's still suspended from the party so
if it's not going to be wolf or Evans
and two best known figures in you kept
apart from Farage who will it be well
the Suzanne Evans wing of the party I'm
throwing their support behind Lisa Duffy
Lisa Duffy is a is a even in
westminister a relatively unknown figure
she's a you Kip party organizer and a
counselor and Ramsey she is seen by her
supporters as the anti Farage as the
antidote to the you kick rugby club
image she's a mom who worked in TK Maxx
for years and her back as viewers that
kind of roll up your sleeves camera but
it is quite a leap to go from town
councillor to party leader then there's
the mep diane james who if Steven wolf
doesn't get on the ballot will be I
think be regarded as as the favorite to
win but the Diane James she's a decent
medium form but there is a question
whether she who's having a very southern
figure is the right person to help you
give try and pick up these working-class
labour seats in the north where most
people in UK pink is their big
opportunity next election they look at
the referendum results how strongly some
of these paces voted for practic and
think that they could pull off a mini
version of what the SMP did in Scotland
after the independence
you